next we have beera cassandra angela
[Applause]
jennifer oh my gosh
oh my god chris appleton give us a
thought about these beautiful
transformations i think the key message
to all of this is
is that everyone looks beautiful before
and after we've established that but
sometimes you just need a little help
along the way sometimes you never need
someone to say i see something you know
by talking like what's your vibe you
know what are you into what would you
aspire to like you know what's your kind
of what do you what outfits do you wear
all these little details sometimes you
just need a little bit of help to be
like this would really complement you
you know and it might be a subtle change
like a side bang or you know a bigger
change like a color transformation it
all is it's not necessarily about
cutting someone's hair off or being you
know wild with a transformation it's
really just about channeling into what
that person wants and how they want to
express themselves and then you know
complementing the look your hair like
with the you know beautiful fullness in
the front and on top is just so
beautiful and becoming you guys look you
look amazing
thank you thank you thank you okay
[Applause]
gina you look so beautiful and bill you
are literally throwing off very
different vibes in your picture
um
now your wife danielle is in the
audience and she nominated you to be
here today um danielle uh thoughts
i think he looks great i think he worked
really hard during the pandemic to uh
bring a little normalcy to kids that
didn't have it and i just think he
really deserves this
bill
i'm sensing swagger am i wrong
no i feel amazing i have to be honest
with you so these people are wizards
[Laughter]
i know i think i made a joke about my
dead libido might have come back to life
their tutelage i i do i i it's so funny
and that's the empowerment i am talking
about and gina i hear you're celebrating
your 40th year as a teacher
will you give us as if you're your
students a little
wisdom
um i think i'm just representing
all teachers everywhere i feel like a
regular person
just so flattered to be here and
kids are great i have the best job in
the world we can transform we can
change ourselves you are perfect already
yeah but if boosting your confidence you
know
gives you that joy then do it and we do
need the experts i am not an expert in
beauty and fashion and hair and yet i've
been raised in an industry my entire
life that revolves around it and i still
look to the experts
so thank you guys thank you thank you
well i am so happy to say that everyone
is going home
with a flat iron from our company um
that i have it's called flower hair and
uh these tools i'm very proud to say
actually just launched and they're
already sold out oh wow
and
i i think
uh the reason that that might be um and
i'm interested in your take is it's a
mini yeah and it's a travel and it's
small listen women want convenience they
want it quick and easy and you know we
don't have hours in the morning it's
about quick easy simple hairstyles and i
think that's why the mini is so popular
just because it's quick and easy you can
travel with it
but it's not they're not intimidated
that's the same with my makeup it's like
how are you going to make it
achievable for the real world not that
thing of like oh only the hollywood
stars can look like that i could never
do that it's like no quick easy simple
and making sure the product does all the
work for you i appreciate you saying
that
[Music]